For thousands of years, man has been practicing meditation, for the health of the soul, the soul and the body
But from a scientific perspective, how does meditation affect your body exactly?
Is it really effective?
It all starts inside the brain! During meditation, brain tests show high activity areas
The virtual system network in particular, is activated when the brain is in rest
And is not focused on the outside world, and has been found to improve memory and self-awareness
And setting goals, do you want to be more considerate to your friends and family? When compare the worlds
The brains of Buddhists with the brains of new meditators, they found that the area associated with
Patience is more intense among Buddhists, literally changed
Your brain waves, we can also measure these frequencies. Pupils have high levels of alpha waves
Which showed a decrease in the feeling of negative mood, tension, sadness and anger
And if that is not enough, meditation automatically changes the size and state of our brain
Studies have shown that after 8 weeks of a meditation program, the gray matter becomes more dense in related areas
Learning, and memory analysis, but the amygdala, which deals
With stress, blood pressure and fear, it has a low gray matter!
When we look at our whole body, we not only notice low blood pressure, but
It can also increase heart rate change, while this may appear to be harmful,
It actually plays a critical role in transporting oxygen and carbon dioxide throughout
Body, do you think you'll get sick? In a study, given to meditators and non-meditators
Influenza virus, and meditators were able to produce significant numbers of antibodies
Thus raising the immune function
If we dive a little deeper, we can see changes at the cell level
Chromosomes contain a protective protein called telomer, which helps to reduce DNA damage and reduce
The number of dead cells has been linked to the telomere length by several epidemics
Cardiovascular depression, diabetes, Alzheimer's and cancer, and, surprisingly, survivors of cancer
When they complete a meditation program, their bodies show a remarkable rise in telomere length
Psychological intervention, especially stress reduction, is believed to have an effect
Directly on the telomerase enzyme, which showed a counteract of default by adding
DNA to shrinked telomer
And, of course, meditation is not to substitute for other medical advice or a healthy lifestyle
We do not want you to come out of here believing that he will treat cancer, but like to go out
A health club can strengthen your muscles and enhance your whole health, it seems to be meditation
Is a way to train the brain for additional health benefits, and as
Your brain controls your whole body, why do not you relax and say "Oom" from time to time?
If you want to train your brain, please go to our book
, Is available for order on site, we have answers to your burning questions
Persistent rumors, and mysterious phenomena, whether you like science
Or just a curious mind, there is something in the book for everyone, and we are excited
To read it and show off your new information to all your friends, thank you again
Over the years, our support has helped us share the love of science
With the world
And participated with the channel in the new scientific weeklies